et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis malade je suis je suis malade on
ne reste pas ses lumières
après avoir dépouillé tous courriers
sans caisson qu'il en reste quelque
chose
enfin de toute façon toutes ces lettres
nous les avons lu et vous savez que nous
faisons grand cas de tous courriers que
nous recevons et nous allons arriver
aujourd'hui
la seconde séquence consacrée à la
campagne d'embellissement des chats
d'être en effet tout le monde rouspète
en dix ans les shadoks ne sont pas beaux
je vous lire cette lettre par exemple
monsieur le directeur il me paraît
difficile de trouver une excuse valable
de l'émission intitulée les shadoks la
prétentieuse et insupportable cacophonie
qu'ils l'annoncent l'abominable laideur
et qu'il est vilain des dessins qui la
composent sans compter l'exaspérant
nasille mans et la vulgarité qu'affecte
monsieur claude piéplu tout cela a pour
effet de battre les records de ridicule
et de mauvais goût c'est monsieur devait
nous d'avesnes à périgueux qui nous
écrit ce je ne sais pas ce que trouve
claude piéplu monsieur de vienne et de
nuire l'autre vulgaire et nasillard
comment est-ce qu'on peut être à la fois
vulgaire et nasillard sûrement se
bouchant le nez en disant des gros mots
ça c'est un exemple quasiment vulgaire
alors nous allons à b lire les shadoks
nous allons les rendre beau nous avons
demandé à monsieur rouxel de nous faire
une seconde séquence grâce à son
histoire de l'art et cette séquence
s'étendra de 1914 à nos jours shadoks
doc
tu veux dire canard en anglais shadoks
apprivoiser par un gangster italo
américains ont battu par elliot ness
shadow croit côté dû l'être shadoks
royal en contre et mon âme à aux shadoks
en croûte
[Musique]
shadoks forains sont des ballons
attention voici maintenant les shadoks
du clergé
ah oui c'est symbolique sa figure d robe
de moine en superstructure shadoks
intéressant et scientifique de pleumeur
bodou shadoks égaré on l'a déjà vu hier
rue jeannotte regardant ajimi à la
télévision avant l'émission
[Musique]
encore un shadok égard et qu'on a déjà
vu hier shadoks dans le bain et pour
finir shadoks de cap canaveral
[Musique]